look  [Music]  Kohn's God on the island ancient species  own desert long before mankind  we're going to bring that a cow  we don't belong here we got it that gosh  come skull island rated pg-13 experience  with an IMAX March 10th  what you're looking at is a monster from  some pie got it from the cavalry I am  the cavalry glad to show that man it  King  mr. come here come go island rated pg-13  experience it in IMAX marched end the  violence notorious for the number of  ships and planes that have gone missing  the 1954 nuclear test warrant test they  were trying to kill something that's  Kong King around here  time to tell that man is king  run  go Highland rated pg-13 experienced at  an IMAX mark end you came here looking  for a track  who awarded am i tracking that's the big  one  before we leave this island we're going  to bring that eight down we're all going  to die together out here haha he should  be coming here  come Delhi lines with pg13 experience at  an IMAX March ends  you